[Music]
[Music]
hello youtube chess lovers my friends
this is gunjan here
welcome to my 45th episode of chess trap
series
just like kasparov if you love sacking
your queen
early in the opening then you come at
the right place
because in today's episode we are going
to look
at wonderful queen sacrifice line
against scandinavian defense from the
white perspective
the critical position arises after the
following opening move order
e4 d5 e captures d5
queen captures d5 and here it doesn't
matter
whether you are knight to c3 or knight
to f3 player
both leads to the same territory
so for example in this game white
continued with
knight to f3 and after the usual
response
bishop to g4 pinning down this knight
white indeed continued with knight to c3
not only attacking the queen but setting
up
a very small trap well
if black foolishly take on f3 then this
is the last time he is going to do it
as after the following sequence
knight captures d5 bishop captures deven
and now the sting in the tail knight
captures c7 check
which not only grabbed the rook in the
corner
but white obtained an exchange just
within
the seventh move of the game
so obviously bishop captures f3 is a big
time mistake
and that's why at this position the most
popular choice by the black cam
is queen goes back to his original place
okay now white claim in the center with
d4 and against this
although knight to f6 is one of the
popular choice
as per the online database there are
more than 30 games
continue with knight to c6
which at first sight looks the obvious
choice
because now black is indeed threatening
bishop captures f3
and then take on d4 something
not easy to defend for the white camp
well white has tried various responses
such as
bishop to e2 as well as bishop to b5
however white can set up a nasty trap at
this point
starting with d5
guess what all the game in the database
continue with knight to e5
putting more pressure on f3 knight
and obviously if white has to defend
this knight
then black has equalized the game
instantly
but nope here is the exact point
where our trap springs into the action
as white has this wonderful
queen sacrifice knight captures e5
bam
so not only grabbing a piece but
attacking that poor bishop
so black doesn't have any choice he has
to
accept this queen sacrifice but after
that
now white revealed his nasty idea
and i hope you already see it right
yup bishop to b5 check
well queen to d7 not only regained the
queen back
but gives wide a completely winning game
so the only critical move in this
position is
c6 counter-attacking the white bishop
okay we are going to take on c6
and now you see the beauty about this
position
white has two deadly discover check
and the most funny part is even though
black can see that one is coming he
can't
stop it
if bishop to e2 then obviously white is
in no hurry he will take this bishop
with his king so accordingly
as per the chess engine the baseline
goes as follow
a6 attacking the bishop
well no price for guessing white's next
move yup
c7 a discover check to the black king
and now after this forcing line
a captures b5 pawn captures d8
with a check black has to take with the
rook
but at the end when white gobble up
this bishop on d1 if you carefully
count the material even though
white has sacrificed his queen at the
end
he emerged with a peace advantage
that's it guys i hope you enjoy and
learn this
high profile queen sacrifice line in the
scandinavian
remember do not play any other moves
except d5 in this position and
when you open and continue with knight
to e5
you just give your opponent a root shock
with
knight captures e5 sacrifice your queen
but winning the game
thank you for watching this video feel
free to like subscribe and comment
and i will meet you in my next episode
very soon
bye and take care